award season has hit in a celebration of
European cinema the finalists for the
european parliament's lux Phillip Rhys
2015 have been revealed and now is where
the fun starts public swings of all
three films kick off across Europe
hitting hard the heart of Europe's
biggest crisis franco-german entry
mediterranea explores immigration for
the eyes of two men from Burkina Faso on
their journey to Italy the film gives a
telling portrayal of the perils faced by
those seeking refuge battling slave
trading to bloody revolts be adding two
ways because I love what I get to be too
deep you know filia lessons of right and
wrong from the premise of Bulgaria and
greases joint production Europe the
lesson a young and idealistic teacher
from a small town in Bulgaria try to
show her students the right path but can
she walk the same line after she gets
embroiled with a loan sharks and rending
of the players could turkish delight
must be the ultimate directorial debut
already short listed as one of the
film's to represent France at the oscars
for best foreign language film it fun
with a similar narrative to Sofia
Coppola's Virgin Suicides the five
sisters at the age of innocence on
prison for dare to explore sexuality in
a conservative society all films will
now be promoted and distributed across
Europe in all of its twenty four
official languages but who wins Emmy PS
can start casting their vote from monday
with a winner's ceremony to take place
in Strasbourg under them the 25th
you